[Music]
hey I'm Alex I'm the producer behind
this video for potato chip onion rings
stay tuned to the end of the video for
some producer tips
[Music]
so this video was born out of my love
for two of the best junk foods in the
world potato chips and onion rings and I
wanted to figure out a way to combine
the two so instead of using a classic
breadcrumb or pink Oh for the onion
rings I decided to bread them and
crushed up potato chips to add variety I
included three kinds of potato chips so
original barbecue and sour cream and
onion but feel free to use your own
favorite flavors
now dredging can get pretty messy so it
tips to keep your hands and your kitchen
clean is to use both of your hands so
one of your hands is gonna be for the
dry and one of your hands is gonna be
for the wet so then you'll avoid
breading your hands along with onion
rings be sure to use a thermometer when
you're frying to make sure your oil gets
to the right temperature that way your
onions will be able to cook through and
also brown on the outside without
burning this recipe is perfect for a
party or if you're watching your
favorite sports team and I hope you try
it and love it as much as I do all right
happy cooking oh yes
[Music]